trapé officiellement partie du
dispositif action coeur de ville la
commune a signé ce mardi 9 octobre avec
les tailles l'ensemble de ses
partenaires la convention le document a
pour objectif d'aider 222 ville en
france à hauteur de 5 milliards d'euros
pour redynamiser les centres-villes une
ville qui n'a plus de coeur en fait
c'est une ville qui meurt donc on a
besoin d'aider les collectivités d'aider
les partenaires parce que le coeur de la
ville bat à nouveau et bat fort le trap
c'est une ville qui irrigue son bassin
c'est un pôle d'attractivité certains
c'est une zone de centralité on a de
nombreux équipements sur trappe qui
attire autour du territoire et donc
c'est important que trappe le reste
vivante au sein de ce territoire et que
son coeur vive premiers projets
programmés dans le centre ville de
trappes le réaménagement de l'ancienne
auberge de l'étoile d'or en kafi culture
est injectée 290 1000 euros
quand je sors du cinéma où je vais quand
je sortirai du cinéma jeux très bien ce
serait la place du 8 mai 45 et j'irai on
a un café un thé vert tout peu importe
et puis et puis là ce soir là il ya un
groupe qui vient jouer de la musique où
il ya un groupe qui vient faire du
théâtre etc
c'est vraiment un lieu un lieu culturel
que nous nous en avons au mot riziers
nous en avons en planeur nous n'en
avions pas ici la convention prévoit
également une rénovation de l'habitat en
centre ville dans le secteur de la
mairie et une aide financière pour les
commerçants de la rue jean jaurès et de
ses alentours afin qu'ils puissent
rénover leurs vitrines il ya des
vitrines qui sont un petit peu anciennes
si je fus dirait vraiment c'est par au
goût du jour quoi il faudrait innover
tout ça que les commerçants ne puisse
pas le faire seul
nous le constatons nous le savons avec
avec ce contrat ils seront aidés
les premiers aménagements sont prévus à
partir de début 2019 les travaux
devraient se terminer dans six ans